quelque chose pour votre bois les est
une histoire des plus sordides y ébranla
russe en parlait ici
oleg sokolov 63 ans est un célèbre
historien un des plus grands experts de
napoléon dans le monde entier conduisez
vous commencerez champions la
reconstitution des champs de bataille un
professeur émérite décoré de la légion
d'honneur par jacques chirac
aujourd'hui le voilà en prison accusé du
meurtre de sa compagne et ancienne
étudiante anastasia yaiche ncaa avec
qu'il a co signé plusieurs ouvrages une
femme de 24 ans dont des parties du
corps démembrés ont été lancés dans les
eaux glacées de la rivière moei cas à
saint pétersbourg des caméras de
surveillance ont capté ces images samedi
ce colloque serait tombé dans l'eau ivre
en essayant de se débarrasser du reste
du cadavre
il prévoyait ensuite se rendre à la
célèbre forteresse pierre-et-paul pour
s'enlever la vie
déguisé en bon à part il a avoué son
geste et le regrette a confirmé ce matin
son avocat
il dit que son client n'était pas lui
même au moment du meurtre et qu'il
pourrait éventuellement exigé une peine
réduite de trois ans selon les experts
associés discuter mais la vôtre et la
mère de la victime elle-même une
policière part d'un meurtre odieux et
certainement prémédité une scie et la
tête de la victime sa fille ont été
retrouvés dans l'appartement du
professeur à la prestigieuse université
d'état de saint-pétersbourg ou alec
sokolow dirige une chaire d'études
plusieurs étudiants soulignent que le
comportement excentrique du professeur
aurait dit sonné l'alarmé
il y a longtemps qu'on dit qu'il a déjà
battu une étudiante devant tout le monde
et qu'il battait aussi sa copine c'était
connu des médias rapporte même que des
plaintes officielles contre sokolov ont
été ignorés étant donné c'est lié avec
l'establishment remarque que la
direction a fermé les yeux
elle est en partie responsable de ce qui
est arrivé à anastasia ce soir
d'ailleurs une pétition circule pour
qu'une enquête soit lancée sur la façon
dont l'université a géré la fin
ici tu as marre alter escaut
radio-canada moscou